hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of my Linda masters I
believe that the fastest and most
effective way to grow a business is to
model the strategies of people who have
already accomplished what you're trying
to do so today we're going to look at a
young entrepreneur who was told wouldn't
last more than six months in business
and went on to become one of the
wealthiest people in the world this is a
story of Henry Ford and the top three
lessons and you can learn from his
success Henry Ford was an American icon
and founder of the Ford Motor Company he
was the son of Irish immigrants and from
an early age children interest in
engineering he set out to learn as much
as he could and took various
apprenticeships and jobs of
manufacturing companies when he was 36
years old he invented the quadricycle in
his spare time it was two bicycles
attached together powered by a gasoline
engine it was a very primitive car after
refining the vehicle he went to see
William H Murphy a lumber tycoon and
investor in Detroit who took it for a
test drive
Murphy agreed with for the
gasoline-powered vehicles would be
fueling the future and it to instantly
formed the partnership Henry Ford was in
business Ford not only revolutionized
the manufacturing industry with assembly
line mass production he also became
where the richest and most well known
people in the world according to Forbes
his net worth in today's dollars would
be 188 point 1 billion dollars over
three times richer than Bill Gates
by following his interest and by taking
steps every day to move his business
forward ford was able to build a
powerhouse company and become one of the
richest people in the world to help you
power up your business here are three
action items you can learn from Henry
Ford action item number one don't quit
I've profiled hundreds of famous
entrepreneurs and one characteristic
that they all have in common is that
they don't quit whatever your business
is make sure you follow your passion and
never give up on your dreams take small
steps every day to build your business
and over time those little steps will
transform into giant leaps forward when
Ford first told the world that he wanted
to create a quality car that could be
mass-produced and affordable he wasn't
taken seriously common thoughts were if
Ford does that he'll be out of business
in six months and the question that
started to be asked was how soon will
Ford blow up but Ford didn't quit he
kept trying until he finally invented
the Model T which went on to sell over
15 million units a record that stood for
the next forty five years according to
Ford
failure is only the opportunity to more
intelligently begin again one who fears
the future who fears failure limits his
activities obstacles are those frightful
things you see when you take your eyes
off your goal there's no man living that
cannot do more than he thinks he can
whether you think that you can or that
you can't you're usually right when
everything seems to be going against you
remember that the airplane takes off
against the wind not with it action item
number two focus on quality as
entrepreneurs we should be proud of what
we create it's your business reputation
and you should do everything you can to
create the best quality product or
service possible it'll not only bring in
more customers to your door it'll also
give you the feeling that what you're
doing is right and has helped me make
people's lives better believe in what
you're doing and make it as good as you
can Ford put his name on the company and
he wanted to make sure that it stood for
quality he felt that if one of his cars
broke down
customer that he was personally to blame
he also didn't believe in rushing into a
new business until he had a hundred
percent confidence in the quality of the
product that would be created he felt
that this was one of the major reasons
why many businesses fail according to
Ford I do not believe in starting to
make until I have discovered the best
possible thing this of course doesn't
mean that a product should never be
changed but I think that it will be
found more economical in the end not
even to try to produce an article until
you have fully satisfied yourself that
utility design and material are the best
quality means doing it right when no one
is looking action item number three
build a team you can't build anything
substantial on your own and at some
point you'll need to build a team around
you make sure that you treat them like
your family and give them a reason to
want to come to work and get excited
about what they're doing think about the
worst boss you ever had and don't do any
of the things that he or she did to you
in hiring new employees Ford ignored all
of the person's history and prior work
experience instead he looked for a
willingness to work and believe that
every person no matter what his or her
past had good in them and only needed to
be given a chance to succeed it was this
faith in his workers abilities and
inspired many of them to do their best
for Ford he also got rid of formal
titles in the company every one was
considered at an equal level and each
had important individual
responsibilities according to Ford it
doesn't matter to me if a man is from
Harvard or singsing we hire the man not
as history I don't believe in titles
they make people think they are superior
coming together is a beginning keeping
together is a progress working together
is success if everyone is moving forward
together then success takes care of
itself
so remember don't quit focus on quality
and build a team to finish up this video
I wanted to share one of my favorite
true stories about Henry Ford and some
of his best quotes when Henry Ford
implemented his assembly line idea he
found that workers were quickly getting
burnt out doing the same thing over and
over again to attract the best people
ford recommended to his stockholders
that they'd pay the workers five dollars
a day twice a daily average wage his
stockholder said no so Ford bought them
out implemented his five dolla day
salary and quickly had people lining up
to work for him
thank you for joining me for another
edition of all in the masters if you
like this video and want to see more
please give it a thumbs up below I'd
also love to hear your thoughts and
feedback if you want to leave a comment
under the video and stay tuned for the
next episode